hallo leute wir sind zurück mit einem
video über deutsche werben und heute
stellen wir euch ein wichtiges deutsches
werk vor
nämlich das wort sehen als erstes
stellen wir euch jetzt die konjugation
vor
los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich sehe du siehst er sie es sieht wir
sehen
ihr seht sie sehen ich habe gesehen
du hast gesehen er sie es hat gesehen
wir haben gesehen
ihr habt gesehen sie haben gesehen
kari was siehst du ich sehe viele leute
die spazieren gehen weil sie wegen des
corona virus nichts anderes machen
können
maria was siehst du wo ich sehe ja nicht
auf einem roller janosch sieht maria
hanisch sieht gar nicht wo er hinfährt
[Musik]
kari hast du das gesehen
ich habe nicht gesehen was passiert ist
janosch hat den stein nicht gesehen
janosch hast du den stein ich gesehen
oh nein ich habe den stein nicht gesehen
wir haben alle den stein nicht gesehen
noch ein kleiner tipp das wort sehen
wird immer mit dem akkusativ gebildet
das objekt oder die person die ihr seht
stehen immer im akkusativ und das üben
wir das hier ist der baum
ich sehe den baum
ich sehe einen baum
das ist das auto ich sehe das auto
ich sehe ein auto das ist die tür
ich sehe die tür ich sehe eine tür maria
was siehst du ich sehe ein restaurant
ich sehe eine speisekarte
ich sehe ein schild ich sehe einen tisch
ich sehe mehrere tische ich sehe ein
schaufenster ich sehe ja nun schon
wieder auf einem roller wenn ihr zu
eurem akkusativ objekt ich noch ein
adjektiv hinzufügen wollt dann bekommt
das adjektiv die gleiche endung wie der
bestimmte artikel im akkusativ hat also
bekommen männliche formen ein n
weibliche formen und die neutrum formen
bekommen es am ende
maria was siehst du ich sehe den blauen
himmel
ich sehe einen blauen himmel
ich sehe die telefonierende carré ich
sehe eine telefonierende kari ich sehe
den nachdenklichen janus ich sehe einen
nachdenklichen janus ich sehe eine
staubige pflanze
ich sehe ein rotes auto aus dem laute
hip hop musik schallt ich sehe eine rote
aufschrift auf dem schaufenster
ich sehe ein rotes fahrrad
ich sehe einen schwarzen stuhl aus
autoreifen
ich sehe einen glücklichen janisch der
schon wieder roller fährt
[Musik]
ich sehe eine blaue tür
ich sehe einen blauen parkautomaten ich
sehe einen wütenden janisch vor dem
parkautomaten ich sehe ein blaues
polizeiauto ich sehe einen sicht
desinfizierenden janosch ich sehe ein
interessantes werbe plakat
ich sehe einen orangenen mülleimer und
jetzt seid ihr dran schreibt gerne in
die kommentare was ihr gerade seht und
wenn ihr weiter üben wollen zum beispiel
mit den wichtigsten deutschen werben
dann schaut euch unsere apps mengen an
dort gibt es einen vokabeltrainer mit
vielen übungen den seht ihr hier gerade
eingeblendet und hier könnt ihr einfach
dem link folgen denn dann kommt ihr
direkt dahin
danke fürs zuschauen und danke maria
dass du da warst bist bei leute halt
[Musik]